[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute
guten abend zusammen sportliches später
zusammengefasst mit katja stresow
guttenberg die schockierenden bilder
mutmaßlicher gräueltaten bestimmen nach
wie vor die kriegs debatten hier ist
unser überblick
was geschah in butter russische soldaten
sollen hunderte zivilisten getötet haben
präsident sie lynskey spricht von
völkermord die russische seite von einem
erfundenen angriff
was geht noch an sanktionen nach den
möglichen kriegsverbrechen weist berlin
russische diplomaten aus und prüft
weitere maßnahmen
jetzt kommt es darauf an die
erderwärmung lässt sich nur einigermaßen
begrenzen wenn die welt in den nächsten
drei jahren radikal umsteuert war der
klimarat
schon jetzt markieren die erschütternden
bilder aus butter von mutmaßlich
hingerichteten ukraine eine neue stufe
in diesem krieg der westen wirft
russland kriegsverbrechen vor moskau
wies dies als inszenierung zurück
sollten sich die vorwürfe bewahrheiten
dürfte der druck noch härtere sanktionen
zu verhängen weiter steigen dazu gleich
mehr zunächst aber der blick in den
großraum kiew aus mehreren orten haben
sich russische soldaten inzwischen
zurückgezogen vergangenen mittwoch
sollen sie butscher verlassen haben das
sagt die regierung in moskau
butscher liegt 35 kilometer nordwestlich
der hauptstadt kiew und hatte vor dem
krieg rund 27.000 einwohner
unsere kollegin katrin eigendorf konnte
sich heute vor ort selbst ein bild
machen
auf der roxeler straße in butter sieht
es fast noch so aus als seien die
russischen soldaten gerade erst
abgezogen nur die leichen der menschen
die hier lagen haben sie inzwischen
geborgen es sind bilder die nur schwer
erträglich sind das innenministerium hat
journalistinnen aus aller welt
eingeladen das zu dokumentieren und
präsident zealand ski ist persönlich
nach untergekommen es ist ihm anzumerken
wie nah es eben geht wenn er schildert
wie hier frauen vergewaltigt familien
hingerichtet wurden das land müsse
kämpfen aber gleichzeitig verhandlungen
führen
ich bin überzeugt dass wir auf dem
territorium der ukraine frieden
erreichen die ukraine kann nicht im
krieg leben denn wir sind im europa des
21 jahrhunderts
in zwar verkehrs bussen die sonst in den
vorstädten fahren bringt das ukrainische
innenministerium
journalistinnen zu den orten aus denen
die russische armee vertrieben wurde
überall auf der straße ausgebrannte
autos von zivilisten zerstörte russische
panzer im dorf macht tisch in zeigt uns
der berater des innenministers einer
familie die nach seiner überzeugung von
russischen soldaten getötet wurde dieser
abschaum hat eine ganze familie
gefoltert geprügelt und ermordet sie
werden dafür zur verantwortung gezogen
werden wir finden alle die diese
schreckliche tat begangen haben
präsident sie lenski bezeichnet butscher
als ein symbol für den völkermord
russlands an den ukrainern die welt soll
das sehen und gleichzeitig wollen die
ukraine genau dokumentieren vielleicht
wird über butscher eines tages vor einem
internationalen gerichtshof verhandelt
werden
wir sind jetzt mit katrin eigendorf in
butter und axel sturm in moskau
verbunden zunächst zu dir kathrin
beklemmend was du in deiner reportage
schildert was wir gerade gesehen haben
es stellen sich jetzt viele fragen wir
werden diese mutmaßlichen hinrichtungen
aufgearbeitet
es ist für die ukrainische regierung
unglaublich wichtig hier wirklich ganz
klar und dezidierten nachzuweisen was
passiert ist warum das ist in seinem
ausmaß so grauenvoll und unvorstellbar
dass man dem wirklich nur eine exakte
und gute aufarbeitung entgegensetzen
kann auch um der russischen propaganda
entgegenzuwirken
ich muss selber sagen als journalistin
habe ich selten so grausame bilder
gesehen wie uns heute vorgeführt wurden
die haben wir alle in unserem film auch
gar nicht zeigen können wir haben tote
gesehen die ganz klar spuren von folter
trugen wir haben eine familie gesehen
die hingerichtet wurde die am boden lag
so etwas führt man normalerweise nicht
journalisten vor das ist schon in seiner
art und weise auch sehr einzigartig was
die ukrainische regierung hier macht um
auch zu dokumentieren was hier passiert
um die welt immer wieder darauf
aufmerksam zu machen dass es sich hier
aus ihrer perspektive um einen
völkermord handelt das sind auch
führende schilderung wir wollen jetzt
auf die russische perspektive blicken
axel sturm in moskau wie ist die haltung
des kreml
ja die haltung des kremls sehr eindeutig
man weiß jegliche verantwortung weit von
sich und zwar kategorisch kreml sprecher
ps kopf kommentierte heute die
ereignisse vor ort würden seiner meinung
nach nicht mit den schilderungen der
ukrainischen seite
korrespondieren sie müssten dringend
überprüft werden es dürften keine
voreiligen schlüsse gezogen werden und
außenminister lavrov ging noch ein
kleines stück weiter und sprach sogar
von einer inszenierung die dazu gemacht
worden sei um dem ansehen russlands zu
schaden das verteidigungsministerium
selbst hatte sich gestern abend schon zu
wort gemeldet und berichtet in der zeit
in der russische truppen vor ort gewesen
seien sei kein einziger mensch zu
schaden gekommen
dann dank an euch beiden danke axel
sturm nach moskau und katrin eigendorf
nach butscher
in anderen teilen der ukraine hielten
die kämpfe an die städte nikolajew und
odessa im süden des landes meldeten neue
russische raketen angriffe in odessa
bekämpften die feuerwehren bereits den
zweiten tag die brände in treibstoff
lagern und einer raffinerie die am
vortag getroffen worden waren in
mariupol scheiterte erneut der versuch
die bevölkerung mit bussen aus der
eingeschlossenen stadt zu holen 90
prozent der infrastruktur seien nach
angaben des bürgermeisters inzwischen
zerstört
die mutmasslichen verbrechen von
butscher bei heute live dazu ein
gespräch mit human rights watch
empfehlen wir gleich ab halb acht auf
unseren social media kanälen und in der
zdf- heute- app und dort also in unserer
app finden sie auch sechs szenarien wie
der ukraine krieg zu ende gehen könnte
und eine einschätzung welches davon wie
wahrscheinlich ist
die schreckensbilder von butscher haben
eine ziemlich große wucht entwickelt der
westen ist jetzt fest entschlossen
härtere sanktionen gegen russland auf
den weg zu bringen obwohl noch in dieser
woche gegen den von vielen geforderten
sofortigen öl und gas lieferstopp gibt
es in berlin allerdings weiter
vorbehalte mehr von thomas reichert die
schrecken von butscher erhöhen in berlin
den druck auf ein energie embargo gegen
russland jeden tag überweisen die
eu-staaten über 700 millionen euro für
öl und gas an putin für ein sofortiges
ende aber soll deutschland noch zu
abhängig von russland sagt robert habeck
das bauen wir jetzt alles zurück und
drehen es um das heißt ja dass wir mit
jedem tag daran arbeiten die
voraussetzungen und die schritte hin zu
einem embargo zu schaffen habe kündigt
an bis zum sommer russische öl importe
zu halbieren auf kohle komplett zu
verzichten das aber bleibt schwierig die
antwort die hh weg gibt es aus meiner
sicht unentschieden er sagt wir machen
weiter und wir warten bis wir einen
ersatz haben aber wir können nicht
jahrelang warten bis lieferungen aus
katar hier an dann ist dieser krieg
längst vorbei währenddessen hat das
auswärtige amt als reaktion auf die
gräuel von butscher die ausweisung von
40 russischen diplomaten mutmaßlichen
agenten angeordnet ihre arbeit schreibt
aus ministerin baerbock ist eine
bedrohung für diejenigen die bei uns
schutz suchen dies werden wir nicht
weiter dulden das haben wir den
botschafter russlands heute nachmittag
mitgeteilt
am abend noch ein einschnitt bei gazprom
germania der deutschen tochter des
russischen energiekonzerns übernimmt
vorübergehend treuhänderisch die
bundesnetzagentur
gazprom hatte den deutschen ableger
gerade ausverkauft an wen blieb unklar
ein risiko für die energieversorgung in
deutschland
die bundesregierung tut das notwendige
um die versorgungssicherheit in
deutschland zu gewährleisten
dazu zählt auch dass wir energie
infrastrukturen in deutschland nicht
willkürlichen entscheidungen des tramp
des kremls aussetzen der weichen in
berlin und brüssel ein fünftes
sanktionspaket gegen russland ohne ein
energie embargo aber mit weiteren
einschränkungen gegen putin unterstützt
den handel und finanzgeschäfte
ja wir müssen noch mal in berlin
erfahren bei theo koll also c/o berlin
zeigt klare kante wir habe es gerade
gehört eine große zahl russischer
diplomaten wird ausgewiesen wie es das
einzuschätzen genauso als klare kante
einerseits wird es putin keine
schlaflose nacht bescheren das jetzt 40
russische diplomaten ausgewiesen werden
andererseits hat es wohl noch nie einen
größeren rauswurf russischer diplomaten
gegeben und man darf getrost davon
ausgehen dass es sich dabei um spione
handelt und die ausweisung gleich von 40
ist zu sagen jedenfalls kenner ein
empfindlicher schlag für die gesamte
spionage abteilung der russischen
botschaft hier die außenministerin hatte
es ausdrücklich auch damit begründet
dass diese botschaftsangehörigen ja
hierzulande jeden tag gegen den
gesellschaftlichen zusammenhalt
gearbeitet hätten und zusätzlich eine
bedrohung für diejenigen sein die hier
bei uns schutz vor dem krieg suchen es
ist in der diplomatischen sprache
jedenfalls eine klare reaktion auf das
grauen in butter auch wenn es im
vergleich zu einem gas embargo und
natürlich dann doch eher symbolpolitik
bleibt und damit zu rechnen ist es
russland im gegenzug die gleiche zahl an
deutschen diplomaten ausweisen wird und
die dame deutlich kleinere deutsche
botschaft in moskau dann stärker
geschwächt wird als umgekehrt danke für
die einschätzung theo koll nach berlin
und wir bleiben mehr oder weniger beim
thema bundespräsident steinmeier übt
selbstkritik und räumt erstmals fehler
in seiner russland politik ein sein
festhalten am pipeline projekt nord
stream zwei sei eindeutig falsch gewesen
man habe an brücken festgehalten an die
russland nicht mehr geglaubt habe und
vor denen die partner deutschlands
gewarnt hätten so steinmeier
um sich möglichst schnell von russischer
energie unabhängig zu machen und um die
eigenen klimaziele einzuhalten macht die
regierung bei der windenergie tempo
umwelt und wirtschaftsministerium haben
sich auf eckpunkte für einen
naturverträglichen ausbau an land
geeinigt geplant sind bundesweit
einheitliche standards zum schutz von
vögeln
windkraftanlagen sind generell auch in
landschaftsschutzgebieten
erlaubt die bundesländer werden
verpflichtet zwei prozent ihrer fläche
bereitzustellen
genehmigungsverfahren sollen so
rechtssicher beschleunigt werden
ja und es stellt sich die frage wie
lässt sich die klimakrise abwenden drei
jahre bleiben uns noch die emissionen
endlich zu senken und eine lebenswerte
erde zu erhalten das sagt der
weltklimarat im ersten teil seines
aktuellen berichtes warnte das un
gremium schon bis zum jahr 2030 könnte
die erde um 1,5 grad erwärmen deutlich
früher als erwartet
im zweiten teil wurden die folgen
benannt hitze armut und hunger im
aktuellen und letzten teil geht es jetzt
um lösungsansätze mehr erfahren wir von
marc hugo
co2 einfach so aus der luft holen diese
anlage in island kann es und speichert
tausende tonnen tief im boden ein
kleiner baustein im kampf gegen die
erderwärmung allein erreicht bei weitem
nicht aus denn auch in den letzten
jahrzehnten stieg der ausstoß von
treibhausgasen
kontinuierlich an wird nicht deutlich
mehr getan geht es auch in zukunft
weiter nach oben und die folgen von mehr
als vier grad erderwärmung wären
katastrophal um das 1,5 grad limit von
paris zu erreichen muss bis 2025 die
trendwende bei den
treibhausgasemissionen kommen sie
müssten schnell und drastisch sinken
die botschaft ist die emissionen jetzt
wirklich zu senken global und zwar um
die 45 prozent bis 2030 co2 muss wir
müssen netto null co2 emissionen um die
mitte des jahrhunderts bekommen und das
erfordert viel politischen willen es
erfordert sehr viel
investitionen der bericht sieht dabei
auch lichtblicke wind und solarenergie
werden immer günstiger und immer besser
es gibt lichtblicke insofern dass wir
gerade bei der technologieentwicklung
gesehen haben dass bestimmte
technologien sich besser entwickelt
haben als wir das erwartet hätten noch
vor 10 oder 20 jahren da es gibt mut
dass wenn man
in solche technologien reingeht
tatsächlich dynamiken besser sein können
als wir sie erwarten und auch das hilft
wenn moore wieder hergestellt werden
speichern sie enorm viel treibhausgas im
torfboden natürlicher klimaschutz in
denen die bundesregierung in den
kommenden jahren milliarden investieren
will
das kommt jetzt vergleichsweise
überraschend die isolation pflicht bei
einer corona infektion fällt weg vom
ersten mai an sollen infizierte nur noch
freiwillig in isolation gehen und sich
nach fünf tagen frei testen können das
hat gesundheitsminister lauterbach
angekündigt das robert koch institut
meldet 41.100 90 29 corinna
neuinfektionen binnen eines tages
26.300 72 weniger als vor einer woche 23
todesfälle kamen hinzu die sieben tage
incident sinkt weiter auf 1400 24,6
jetzt nach ungarn wo sich viktor orban
feiern lässt für den deutlichsten
wahlsieg seiner partei seit dem ende des
kommunismus bzw einer partei selbst ein
bemerkenswert breites oppositionsbündnis
von links bis rechts konnte den triumph
von orbáns fidesz partei nicht
verhindern jetzt steht ein ganz starker
mann vor seiner fünften amtszeit als
ministerpräsident und die eu vor
weiteren konflikten wolf christian
ullrich
budapest am tag nach urbans triumph das
ganze land in den farben seiner
fidesz-partei so zeigt es die zeitung
sieht so aus als hätten nur wenige leute
veränderungen gewollt
ich hätte mich gefreut wenn jemand
anderes gewinnen
viktor orban triumphiert an diesem
wahlabend bekommt dem parlament wieder
zwei drittel der sitze ungarn ungarn
offen seine anhänger
das ist ein gewaltiger sieg das wird man
heute bis zum mond hören und in brüssel
ganz sicher
kampfansage eines mannes der sein
autokratisches machtsystem mit dem geld
europäischer steuerzahler speist die eu
politiker fordern schon länger wegen
mängeln bei der rechtsstaatlichkeit
gegner für ungarn zu sperren alle neuen
straßen neue internetleitung neue
schulen werden zu 90 prozent von der eu
mitfinanziert wenn dieses geld plötzlich
fehlt dann glaube ich werde druck auch
der ungarin und ungarn auf die regierung
von orban plötzlich sehr groß scharfe
kritik an den umständen der wahl kam
heute von osze wahlbeobachter die
ungleiche berichterstattung in ungarn
und das fehlen von debatten zwischen den
spitzenkandidaten hinderte die wähler
daran eine informierte entscheidung zu
treffen
so sieht es auch der geschlagene
spitzenkandidat der opposition
nach zwölf jahren gehirnwäsche kann
orban jede wahl in diesem land gewinnen
indes konnte an seiner seite standen am
abend nur zwei weitere oppositionschefs
die anderen vier blieben einfach weg so
zerfiel die vereinte opposition am abend
ihre niederlage
auch in ungarns nachbarland serbien ist
am wochenende gewählt worden klarer
sieger der präsidenten- und
parlamentswahl sind staatspräsident
alexander witsch und seine partei dpj
gilt als gemäßigter nationalist und kann
nun ohne stichwahl seine zweite amtszeit
antreten er möchte sein land in die eu
führen pflegt aber gleichzeitig gute
beziehungen zu dem ihr putin die
opposition beklagt unregelmäßigkeiten
bei der gestrigen wahl
und hier geht es sportlich mit katja
stresow weiter und wir beginnen diesen
sportlichen montag mit der fußball
bundesliga borussia mönchengladbach
hätte gestern den dritten sieg
nacheinander klar machen können
stattdessen muss das team von adi hütter
froh sein über den einen punkt der es am
ende geworden ist gladbach spielt 1 1
gegen mainz und einer stand aber ganz
klar im mittelpunkt
anerkennung von allen seiten für yann
sommer
gladbachs torhüter gestern mit geradezu
unglaublichen reflexen der schweizer
rettet seinem team gegen in der zweiten
hälfte überlegene mainzer einen überaus
schmeichelhaften punkt dabei hat
mönchengladbach stark begonnen verdiente
führung durch embryo in der 33 minute
nach der pause aber baut gladbach mal
wieder bedenklich ab dass es für mainz
nur noch zum 1 1 ausgleich durch ohne
sieg reicht liegt einzig und allein an
yann sommer der
sc freiburg hat nun doch einspruch gegen
die wertung des spiels gegen den fc
bayern münchen eingelegt die bayern
hatten samstag nach einem wechselfehler
16 sekunden lang mit 12 statt elf
spielern auf dem platz gestanden und das
spiel mit 4 zu 1 gewonnen jetzt muss das
dfb sportgericht entscheiden und noch
zum tennis laura siegemund hat mit ihrer
russischen partnerin vera zvonareva den
doppel wettbewerb des wta turniers von
miami gewonnen im einzel der männer
triumphierte ein 18 jähriger sein name
carlos alcaraz aus spanien ja besser
curacon chronisch kopf herz und so das
lebensmotto von carlos alters dass sie
muss ein großvater vererbt hat gegen
caspar ett aus norwegen demonstrierte
der 18 jährige einmal mehr seinen
unbedingten siegeswillen
in zwei sätzen gewann er in miami sein
erstes masters turnier und schraubte
seine jahresbilanz auf 18 siege in 20
matches sein vorbild rafael nadal
twitter zur glückwünsche und sogar könig
philipp ii gratulierte alcaraz per
telefon
schönes motto der seine art danke katja
so keine ohrfeige wie bei den oscars die
grammys sind in las vegas nicht nur
skandalfrei sondern auch ziemlich
politisch über die bühne gegangen beim
wichtigsten musikpreis wurde prominent
an die opfer des ukraine krieges
erinnert präsident see lenski schickte
eine videobotschaft
verliebte doppeln bekam bruno mars mit
seiner band six sonic die auszeichnung
für den song des jahres
mit elf nominierungen ins rennen
gegangen war jean bart ist der soul
musiker räumte insgesamt fünf grammys ab
sehr bewegt so kleine korrektur noch zum
schluss unserer reporter kollegin katrin
eigendorf war für unsere live schalte
vorhin in kiew und nicht wie ich gesagt
habe in butter sorry dafür so leider die
ganze woche wind und regen mehr weiß
gleich katja horneffer einordnende
information wieder um 21 uhr 45 mit
christian sievers im heute journal das
gesamte heute 19 team bedankt sich für
das interesse wünscht noch einen
angenehmen abend und möchte sie morgen
gerne wieder sehen bis da
[Musik]
genannt der schnee vom wochenende ist
schon fast wieder passe allerdings heute
nacht kann es hier noch leicht schneien
dann aber wird es deutlich regnerischer
windiger und milder von westen am
donnerstag kommt sogar ein richtiges
sturmtief zu uns heute nacht also fällt
noch etwas schnee regen in den östlichen
und südlichen mittelgebirgen sonst
regnet es häufig ganz im norden und ganz
im süden bleibt es wohl trocken ist kann
auch noch mal glatt sein vor allen
dingen in den mittelgebirgen da sinken
die temperaturen auf plus 1 bis minus 1
grad sonst bleibt die nacht bei 7 bis 3
grad milder und morgen liegen die
höchsttemperaturen zwischen 6 grad in
der oberpfalz und 12 grad am niederrhein
und besonders über der mitte
deutschlands regnet es morgen kräftig am
anfang an hier in den östlichen und
südlichen mittelgebirgen auch noch ein
bisschen schnee regen dabei sein ganz
anders sieht es im nordosten aus da
zeigt sich häufiger die sonne der wind
kommt aus westlichen richtungen am
mittwoch wird es dann vor allen dingen
in der nordhälfte kräftig regnen am
donnerstag überquert deutschland ein
sturmtief bei temperaturen von acht bis
15 grad und am freitag droht im
südwesten intensiver dauerregen guten
abend